marie la piste est avec nous paris marie
tu as fait un truc de ouf cette semaine
oui j'étais incrusté dans un défilé état
parce que c'est le plus grand show
attendu dans la fashion week aujourd'hui
à paris parce que pour ne pas citer une
marque lequel ils veulent se mettre un
peu en concurrence
ils veulent refaire un peu le show
victoria secret's d'accord merci des
autres marques de lingerie est notre
leader et un salaire oui et léopold ii
le goût des choses simples
ne passons pas à côté donc y'a sochaux
qui se faire volant gare aussi à le tout
paris à tongres a tant d'atouts gratin
il va t'en et je me suis infiltré et au
moment où quoi toi qui es là bas tu es
là bas donc on fait là bas tu veux voir
le suivait et qui était monté tu t'es
mis en petite tenue
elle est folle givet déjà regardé
j'aille à regarder
[Musique]
la blague
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
non
je
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes vous êtes pour vous incruster
il commençait pas tout alors je me mets
je vois où est le vigile évidemment été
sous moi qui étais pas non plus faire
face il ya une rambarde qui est pas non
plus épaisse et pour le clou du
spectacle pages les enjamber g il
perçoit d'après une fois que vous êtes
sur le podium c'est fini j'ai froid j'ai
fermé les yeux comme ça pendant 35
secondes
il s'est rien passé non rien de rien
battus vous êtes très belle on gagne ou
on savait déjà petits petits bouts
l'alerté après comment s'est passé après
mais ils ont rien capté
non non vous êtes reparti comme ça merci
avec lui-même qu'un nom c'est ouf
applaudissements polis
[Applaudissements]